-I think that I can say
that we are friends.
-Yes. Absolutely.
-And I'm wondering if we might
be best friends.
And I have a game that we could
play to prove it.
It is time for the "Best Friends
Challenge." Here we go.
♪ -Best friends challenge ♪
♪ Oh, yeah ♪
-Totally, see?
And you're her and I'm her.
And you're that dog
and I'm that dog.
-Alright. So the game works
like "The Newlywed Game"
but for friends,
so we're going to take turns
reading questions about each
other from the best friends box,
and we'll try to write down
the same answer.
And we didn't plan
any of this out.
-Oh, my God. We haven't.
Perhaps we should have.
-I think we probably actually
should have planned it.
Alright, here we go.
-That's a big pen.
-Here we go.
I will read the --
It is a big pen. I'm gonna read
the first question.
Alright, "What would I order at
McDonald's?"
Breakfast included.
-Oh, wow.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
-What would I order
at McDonald's?
Ooh!
Yeah, alright.
I think I know what you think
it might be,
but I don't know if it's that.
-It's got to be that.
-No, because I'm too old
for that.
-No, you're not. It's seasonal.
[ Laughter ]
-Ooh!
-You did put McRib.
-Yeah, I did!
[ Laughter ]
You know you would order
the McRib.
-No, man, you know I walk in,
"Give me the McMuff."
You know what I'm saying, dude?
[ Sad trombone plays ]
[ Laughter ]
-You shouldn't see what my mouth
is saying right now.
[ Laughter ]
Okay, so.
Should we do our next -- "Taxi."
"Taxi 2."
-Alright. Here we go.
-Alright. Okay.
So, next question.
-We'll get at least one right.
-"When I was little, what did
I want to be when I grew up?"
-"Whant."
[ Laughter ]
Gosh, you're already getting me
giggly. Alright.
What did you "whant" to be
when you grew up?
[ Laughter ]
When you were little, what did
you want to be when you grew up?
I mean, oh, gosh,
obvious, I think.
That, but...
[ Groans ]
I don't know this about you.
♪♪
I know it's got to be wrong,
right?
This is too obvi,
and you're writing too long.
-Mm-hmm.
[ Laughter ]
-Alright, you're getting
specific.
-Yeah.
I'm pretty sure I knew this.
-You know this definitely.
You're you.
-I'm sure we've talked
about this.
-We must have, right?
I said singer.
-Oh.
-Yeah.
[ Drumroll ]
You do know me.
And I said famous tennis player
Bjorn Borg.
[ Laughter ]
[ Buzzer ]
-You wanted to be Bjorn Borg?
[ Laughter ]
Is that --
That's what you wanted to be?
-Don't you remember?
-Of course.
Of course I remember that.
You had the headband
and tried growing a beard.
-Yeah, it was like come on.
-Come on. I think singer, right?
-Yeah, you know me.
You know me.
I do love tennis, though.
And Bjorn Borg.
-Oh, this is interesting.
-Oh, what is it?
-"What was my wrap gift to you
on 'Taxi,' and what was yours?"
-Yo.
We breathed in way too much
laughing gas.
[ Laughter ]
-We did.
Wait, I got to say --
What was mine?
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, man.
I should know this.
-I definitely know
what you got me.
Hmm.
♪♪
-That's a lot of writing.
[ Laughter ]
-And then yours was...
Alright, what did you think
it was?
Let me see.
-Was it a guitar?
[ Drumroll ]
-Yes. This is exactly right.
Alright, so I got you a keychain
that says, "I love Jimmy."
[ Laughter ]
And you got me
a Rickenbacker guitar.
And then you got weed
for the crew.
[ Laughter ]
[ Ding! ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Right?
-And like the B.E.T. Award,
I was ahead of my time.
-That's exactly right.
[ Laughter ]
-You know, it's all good.
-But I do remember that.
Everyone loved it.
It was so good.
-We had a good crew.
A very happy crew.
-Yeah, very happ--
I'm happy that was the last day
of work.
-We got nothing done.
-I love that guitar.
It was gorgeous.
Alright, the last one here.
Come on. Let's get this.
-Tricky business.
-You ask the question.
Here we go.
We're going to get this.
I already know we're BFFs.
We don't even need to get this.
But let's just do it for fun.
-Okay, "what was the first album
I ever purchased?"
-It could be anything. Wait.
Oh, yeah, give me the vibe.
Alright.
Oh, I'm already getting
the vibe from you.
Okay.
♪♪
I got it. I got it.
-I guess I have to
guess this too.
-Do I have to say the album?
-No, you can just give me
the artist if you want.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
-If it's this, you are
the coolest person of all time.
Mine was like -- I'm trying
to think if mine was either
"Weird" Al Yankovic...
[ Laughter ]
...or Barry Manilow, "Mandy,"
I think could have been mine.
-I know it was Barry Manilow.
-It probably was Barry Manilow.
-It was Barry Manilow.
Alright, is this possible?
First album?
[ Drumroll ]
-Come on, come on,
you can do it.
You can do it, Jimmy.
Come on, root him on!
Root him on, y'all!
Come on, Jimmy! Come on!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Prince, "Purple Rain"?
-Yo!
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Ding! ]
Yo!
-Is that right?
-My best friend!
♪♪
My best friend, my best friend!
-I love you!
That's my best friend!
Queen Latifah, everybody!